hi listeners Jenny here you often ask us
how you can learn more about the topics
we cover and deepen your impact As
Leaders I want to take a quick minute to
suggest one solution Stanford Graduate
School of businesses lead online
business program in this yearlong online
program participants hone fundamental
business skills they connect and tap
into a Global Network and they emerge
with an innovation mindset lead is now
accepting applications through February
7th so go check it out at grow.
stanford.edu
leow to learn
more when it comes to effective
communication confidence is key I'm Matt
Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to this quick
thinks episode of think fast talk smart
the
podcast confident communication boils
down to a simple equation confidence
equals comp competence the more
confident you are the more competent and
credible your audience will see you as
of course you can take this to an
extreme and I am certainly not
suggesting that we all be overconfident
or arrogant when we interact with others
believe me I work and teach in Silicon
Valley and I spend a lot of time talking
about confidence versus arrogance now
the biggest barrier to confident
communication is anxiety most people
upwards of 75% of people feel an ious in
high stakes communication situations be
it written or spoken inperson or virtual
with large audiences or small
synchronous or
asynchronous I think I covered all the
bases there today with the help of clips
from experts from previous thinkfast
talk smart episodes I hope to provide
you with several communication anxiety
management techniques to help you feel
more comfortable and confident when you
communicate as a guide to help us learn
these techniques we'll be talking about
the ABCs of anxiety management that
stands for Effective behavioral and
cognitive effective symptoms relate to
how we feel and respond when stressed or
under pressure to perform well many of
us feel intensely negative when we find
ourselves in high stakes communication
situations we often feel that once these
negative feeling starts we can't do much
to stop them it feels like a train has
left the station yet there are few
things we can do for example we can use
techniques that come from the study of
mindfulness that encourage us to
acknowledge unhelpful or negative
feelings that arise and remind ourselves
that feeling anxious in speaking is
completely normal in fact it is unnormal
not to feel nervous also these negative
feelings do not Define us as Professor
Christian wheeler shares in episode 18
when he talks about his class on
spontaneous management
a lot of people feel anxious you know
even giving a a planned scripted
presentation in front of others and how
much worse is that when you're dealing
with circumstances that you can't
completely control such as an a question
and answer session that uh goes
differently than you anticipated or or
just being asked to make spontaneous
remarks about something sometimes when
we get in these situations we can get a
little anxious and then we get anxious
about being anxious we feel bad about
being anxious and that's that's where
the problem starts there's nothing wrong
with with being uncomfortable the
problem is with your discomfort at being
uncomfortable and so we work on
exercises teaching people to to be in
that situation and to respond in that
situation with a sense of calm they can
acknowledge that they feel a little bit
anxious but they're not going to dwell
on it and they're going to trust their
minds to Bubble Up the necessary
responses that they have in that moment
by becoming aware of your feelings and
how they impact you you create a sense
of agency which provides you with the
ability to reframe your negative
thoughts in a more positive way another
effective technique comes from Stanford
lecturer and award-winning author Kelly
mcgonagle who in episode 69 shares how
she sees her anxiety as a
signal what I have come to Value about
anxiety is it's a sign that I care so
you know for example when I start to
feel anxious now I will say to myself my
heart is in it the purpose of any really
interesting communication should be for
the other person to have interesting
thoughts in their own head about your
work it's not to convince them that your
work is right or important or that you
know everything about it they are having
their own interesting spontaneous
thoughts and questions that's the
measure of success Beyond effective
experiences of anxiety that we can
address through acknowledging and
reframing our fear and reminding
ourselves that it is normal and natural
we need also to address behavioral
symptoms and sources behavioral
experiences as the name suggests relate
to behaviors such as rapid heart rate
sweating stuttering and oh so many more
one tried and true method to address
behavioral anxiety issues is deep
breathing Andrew huberman host of The
huberman Lab podcast in episode 66
shared his thoughts on controlling our
autonomic nervous system and
breathing there are direct control
points through which we can control the
autonomic nervous system meaning that we
can dial down the level of alertness or
increase the level of calmness when you
you are stressed you are breathing less
deeply the most common the most common
advice is to take a deep breath it turns
out that's exactly the wrong advice oh
no the exhale emphasized breathing leads
to much more rapid activation of the
calming arm of the nervous system and
and the it turns out you don't just want
to Exhale you want to do a double inhale
so inhale through the nose and then
before you exhale sneak in a little bit
more air and then do a long exhale and
you do this just one to three times
breathing in this manner slows down your
heart rate slows down your speaking rate
and can help you feel calmer here are a
few other quick tips to reduce some of
the behavioral symptoms many of us
experience when we get shaky that's
adrenaline trying to move us from threat
to safety use big broad gestures or step
towards your audience if you're in
person that movement will help the
shakiness Abate some of us like myself
sweat when we get nervous that's your
core body temperature going up your
blood is pumping faster your vessels are
tightening this causes your blood
pressure to go up it's like you're
exercising by cooling ourselves down we
can reduce the blushing and sweating a
great way to do this is simply to hold a
cold bottle of water or glass of water
in your hands this reduces your core
body temperature we've all done this in
reverse on a cold morning if we've held
a warm cup of coffee or tea and felt it
warming us up some of us get dry mouth a
great way to reverse that is to suck a
lozen chew some gum or drink some warm
water right before you speak finally GSB
Professor Jeffrey feffer in episode 34
reminds us that it is important to do
physical warm-ups to calm ourselves down
well I think you know when I have built
English and suie Dalal who are
co-founders and of the San Francisco
playhouse come and teach my session on
acting with power that they give the
students fabulous advice which I will
pass on on their behalf uh to your
listeners and that is to warm up so they
talk about getting your voice warmed up
getting your body warmed up obviously
not public you know match you're going
to go play football before and S
particularly given our ages but even
before before you went on the football
field you would probably do some
stretches and some exercises to warm up
and the same advice holds for speech and
and communication you want to warm up so
that when you enter the moment you are
as relaxed and as ready to go as you can
the many people I teach and coach find
these behavioral hacks super helpful
Beyond effective and behavioral the
third category that we need to address
is cogn nitive cognitive symptoms affect
our brain's ability to function smoothly
we become flustered or forgetting what
we intended to say additionally we fall
victim to all of the bad things we say
to ourselves something academics call
negative self-talk we can do several
things to help avoid these issues here
is advice from Stanford Professor
Aaliyah crum in episode 40 followed
immediately by guidance from Harvard
Business School Professor Allison wood
Brooks in episode 73
most people have the mindset that
stressful situations are inherently
debilitating they're going to ultimately
make us sick make us struggle make us
crumble under
pressure and when you look at the truth
about stress which is like most things
very complicated you realize that that
is a simplified assumption it's not
necessarily wrong but it's only one way
of viewing stress and you start to
realize that the true nature of stress
is more complex and in fact there's a
whole other side of stress that reveals
to us that the body stress response the
Mind stress response was not designed to
be debilitating but instead designed to
be uh to help us Elevate our performance
and behavior to meet the demands we're
facing there's a whole side of stress
that shows that it can have enhancing
qualities on our cognitive functioning
our physical health and on how we behave
and interact with others and so our work
is not necessarily to find out the truth
of stress what is or what isn't but to
look at how our mindsets the cor
assumptions we make about it shape how
we respond in stressful situations and
what we've shown is that if we can get
people to open their minds to this
notion that stress can be in ing that
stress can help you rise to a newer
level of understanding can deepen your
connection with others can make us even
physiologically grow tougher and
stronger having that Focus shifts our
attention and behaviors and ways that
make that mindset more
true so we tried a very simple coping
strategy a very simple intervention and
the question was can people refr frame
their anxious feelings as excitement and
it's a really simple idea but the reason
that it works is because when we feel
anxious we have this
Daisy Instinct that we should try and
calm down like really powerful everybody
feels like they should calm down when
they're anxious and that's hard right
that that that would require that we
mitigate the physiological signs of
anxiety so you're racing heart sweaty
Palm fiked cortisol in your body you're
trying to like push those down as well
as move from the negative veence right
like a negative emotion like anxiety and
move into the positive zone of calmness
and that two-step move reducing the
physiological signals and moving from
negative to positive it's pretty much
impossible it's very very hard
especially the physiological component
of it so instead what reframing as
excitement does is it allows you to stay
in that high arousal Zone own you're not
trying to combat your automatic
physiological processes but instead
you're just doing this mental reframe
from negative to positive both Aaliyah
and Allison point to how our mindset
affects how we feel about our anxiety by
changing our mindset what we focus on we
can feel less nervous and perhaps even
excited further we can refocus our
negative selft talk by adopting positive
affirmations like I have value to add
and I've got this
these mantras redirect our thoughts and
help us to be more positive in how we
approach our speaking with this
understanding of effective behavioral
and cognitive techniques now we need to
put these into action and create what I
call an anxiety management plan or amp
for decades now I've encouraged my
students and people I coach to create a
personalized anxiety management plan
that they can leverage whenever they're
put on the spot to speak having a plan
in handy helps you manage both the
symptoms and sources that make anxiety
challenging an amp serves as a recipe
you can follow to calm yourself down so
you can communicate at your best I hear
from students from years ago who share
how they are all still using their amps
to help them in fact just the other week
I heard from a student who leveraged his
plan to help him deliver what he called
a killer toast for his brother's wedding
I have found that the best anxiety
management plans consist of three to
five tech techniques that you think will
help you feel more comfortable and
confident in your highstakes
communication try to pick examples from
each of the effective behavioral and
cognitive categories to make sure you
cover all the bases I still get nervous
in certain situations in fact I was
recently in Australia presenting in
front of many distinguished Stamford
alumni and I freaked out a bit luckily I
used my anxiety management plan to calm
myself down my plan consists of three
steps from an effective point of view I
reminded myself that it's normal to be
anxious in these situations and it
reminded me that I really care about
what I'm saying from a behavioral
perspective I held a cold bottle of
water to help reduce my sweating and
blushing and then finally from a
cognitive perspective I said to myself I
have value to bring this plan helped me
to feel more comfortable and to deliver
a good communication once you have a
plan you next need to test it out your
plan is really a set of hypotheses some
may turn out to be helpful and others
less so simply iterate and adjust until
you find what works for you we are
profoundly curious about what your
anxiety management plans might sound
like do us a favor create your anxiety
management plan and then send it to us
at thinkfast stanford.edu we'll collect
listeners anxiety management plans and
share some of the best practices we
learned
the bottom line is this there are many
things we can do to help ourselves feel
more comfortable calm and confident when
we communicate this helps us do better
and it helps our audience to focus more
clearly on what we're saying without
being distracted by our anxiety signals
I encourage all of you to create your
own anxiety management plans based on
the ABCs of anxiety management and I
look forward to hearing about your
success
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business
this episode was produced by H Ash Jenny
Luna and me Matt Ibraham our music was
provided by Floyd Wonder for more
information and episodes find us on
YouTube or wherever you get your
podcasts and please make sure to
subscribe and follow us on LinkedIn and
give us a five-star rating and tell your
friends families and co-workers about
think fast talk
smart